The following
content is provided
under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue
to offer high-quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: So I'll
briefly review
what we were doing last time.
We are gradually
developing the structure
that we need for thermodynamics.
And the first thing that we
did was to state that it wholly
depends on the existence
of equilibrim--
is the first and foremost
thing that we need to know,
is that the objects that we
are studying in thermodynamics
are in equilibrium.
And once they're
in equilibrium, we
can characterize them
by a set of properties.
So there's a list of
coordinates that I
would have the list here.
And we saw that
since we will also
need to think in terms of
mechanical work, a good place
to start-- and since we are
familiar with mechanical
coordinates-- is to enumerate
here the mechanical coordinates
that we would describe
the system with.
And we said that we could,
in principal, characterize
or divide those
coordinates in the form
of some generalized
displacements
and the corresponding
conjugate forces.
And typically, the displacements
are extensive proportional
to the size of your system.
The forces are intensive.
And the work is related to
the product of those two
in some fashion.
One of the things that
I will do throughout
is to emphasize that one of
the main materials that we
are going to look at, and
illustrate the concept with,
is the gas.
And in particular,
the version of the gas
that is the ideal gas.
But forgetting the ideal
part for the time being,
the coordinates that we use
to describe the gas with
is V and pressure.
And actually, we
saw that in order
to ultimately be consistent
with how we will define work,
it is good to think
of minus pressure
as the appropriate force.
And so basically, then if I want
to characterize the equilibrium
state of a gas, I
need, for example,
to specify where I
lie in this P-V plane.
OK so that's the
first thing to know.
But then we also realize
that mechanical coordinates
are insufficient to describe
the properties of the systems
that we encounter.
For example, if we are
thinking in terms of a spring
and we pull on
the spring-- so we
are looking at the relationship
between displacement
and the force-- the result
that we get how easy it
is to pull on this depends
on something else--
depends on temperature.
So somehow, we need to
include these properties that
have to do with heat
and heat transfer
in order to have a complete
description of systems
that are in equilibrium.
And so going along
that direction,
we started with the Zeroth Law.
And the statement
of the Zeroth Law
was the transitivity
of equilibrium--
if two objects
are in equilibrium
with each other they are--
two objects are in equilibrium
with a third object,
they're also in equilibrium
with each other.
And we saw that
what that means, is
that once I am at some point
in this coordinate space,
I know that there
exists some function.
I don't know its
functional form.
This empirical temperature
and being in equilibrium
means that there is
this important function
of the coordinates
of the first system
equal to some other functional
or form potentially,
depending on the coordinates
of the second system.
And this empirical temperature
has to be the same.
We said that this is kind
of like being on a scale,
and having a balance
between different things,
and then they are in
balance with each other.
So we know that there's
something like mass.
Now, when we describe this
in the context of the gas,
we noted that for all gases in
the limit that they are dilute,
the isotherms-- the places that
would correspond in this case
to always being in
contact with the object
is at a fixed temperature,
form these hyperboles.
So the isotherms in
the limit of dilute
are of the form PV is
proportional to time span.
We can call that theta.
We can use that, even, to
define the ideal gas temperature
scale, provided that we
choose some proportionality
coefficient which
was selected so
that the temperature
of water, ice,
steam, coexistent at
a particular value.
OK, so that's the specific
property of the ideal gas
as far as its
temperature is concerned.
The next thing that
we did was to look
at how changes are carrying a
system, a particular system.
And we found that if you take
the system from one location
in its coordinate space
to another location,
do it in a manner that does not
involve the exchange of heat.
So basically, you
idealize this thing
and isolate it from
any other source--
that the amount of
work-- and we can then
calculate mechanical work--
the amount of mechanical work
that you do is only a function
of the initial and final
states, and does
not depend on how
you supply the work that
produces this, et cetera.
And so that immediately reminded
us of conservation of energy,
and a suggestion that there
exists this function that
depends on where you are in this
coordinate representation that
gives the total energy
content of the system.
What was important
was that, of course,
we want to relax the condition
of making changes over which
there is no heat
exchange to the system.
And more generally then,
we said that the changes
that we obtain in energy are
the sum of the two components--
the amount of work
that you do on it,
and that we know how to measure
from our various mechanical
prescriptions.
But if there is a shortcoming
from the internal energy
function that we had
constructed previously,
and the work that we compute
for a particular process,
we say that in
that process, there
was some heat that
went into the system.
And it is, again,
important to state
that this dE really only depends
on the initial and final state.
So this depends on state.
While these things-- that's
why we put a bar on them--
depend on the particular
path that we take.
Now again, if you
ask, well, what can
we say in this context
for the ideal gas?
And there is the very
nice experiment by Joule
where he said, let's
isolate our gas, let's say,
into two chambers.
These are kind of rigid
balls, very nicely isolated
from the environment.
Initially, the gas is confined
completely onto one side.
So let's say that the
initial state is over here,
with this volume.
And then we release this.
And so the gas goes and expands.
And we wait sufficiently.
We wait sufficiently.
Ultimately, we're
settled to a place,
let's say over here--
the final state.
Now, it's important
to say that I
don't know the intermediate
state of this transformation.
So I can't say that
somewhere between t
equals to zero when
I open the valve,
and t goes to infinity where
the whole thing is settled.
Zero and infinity points I know.
In between, I can't
really have an idea
of where to put my system.
It is at non-equilibrium
by construction.
But this is a process
that by definition I
follow the path
along which there
was no input either in
the form of work or heat
into the system.
It was isolated.
So all I know for sure is
that however amount of energy
I had initially is
what I have finally.
The observation of
Joule was that if we
do this for the case
of a dilute gas,
I start with some
initial temperature Ti.
I go to some final temperature.
But that final
temperature is the same
as the initial temperature.
And that is actually
why I put both
of these points on
the same isotherm
that I had drawn before.
So although I don't know
anything about the in
between points, I know that this
is the property of the system.
And essentially,
we know, therefore,
that although in
principle I can write E
as a function of
P and V, it must
be only a function
of the product PV,
because it only-- P
changes in the process.
V changes in the process.
But PV remains constant.
Or if you like, E
is really a function
of T, which is related
to the product.
And sorry about being kind
of inconsistent with using T
and theta for temperature.
OK, any questions?
So this is kind of recap
of what we were doing.
All right, now, it
would be good if we
can construct this
function somehow--
at least theoretically, even.
And you would say, well,
if I had this spring,
and I didn't know whether it
was a Hookean or a nonlinear
spring, what I could do
is I could pull on it,
calculate what the force
is, and the displacement,
and integrate f dx and
use the formula that quite
generally, the mechanical
work is sum over i,
let's say Ji dxi.
Now, of course you
know that I can only
do this if I pull
it on this spring
sufficiently slowly, so
that the work that I do
goes into changing the
internal energy of the spring.
And then that would be
a contribution to dE.
If I do that rapidly, then
it will send this spring
into oscillation.
I have no idea, again,
where the system
is in the intermediate stages.
So I can use this
kind of formula
if, in this type of
diagram that indicates
the state of the system, I
proceed sufficiently slowly
so that I can put points
that corresponding
to all intermediate states.
And so that's for things that
are sufficiently slow and close
to equilibrium that
we call quasistatic.
And so in principal, I guess
rather than opening this
immediately, I could
have put a slow piston
here, change its position
slowly, so that at each stage
I can calculate where
I am on the PV diagram.
And I could have calculated
what the work is, and used
this formula to calculate
the contribution of the work
to the change in
internal energy.
OK, now I said that
it would be ideal--
and what we would like
to do, ultimately--
is to have a similar
formula for dQ.
And if we look by analogy,
we see that for W,
you have J's times the X's.
The forces are the
things that tell us
whether systems are in
equilibrium with each other.
So two-- if I have,
let's say, a piston
separating two parts
of the gas, the piston
will not move one
direction or the other
if the pressure
from one direction
is the same as the pressure
from the other direction.
So mechanical equilibrium
tells us that J's are the same.
And it suggests that
if I want to write
a similar type of formula for
heat, that the thing that I
should put here is temperature
or empirical temperature, which
is, again, a measure
of thermal equilibrium.
And then the question
that would immediately
jump onto you is, what
is the conjugate that I
have put for the displacement?
And you know
ultimately that it is
going to end up to be entropy.
And so the next part of
the story is to build that.
And we're going to do that
through the Second Law
of Thermodynamics.
Any questions?
Yes.
AUDIENCE: I mean, this is
kind of a semantics question,
but what always confuses
me in thermodynamics
when we talk about quasistatic
is, I mean, if it isn't
quasistatic, introductory
formation of [INAUDIBLE]
doesn't really give a
means to address it.
So we have to rely on the
fact that it's quasistatic.
And the only way
we could check it
is to assume that what
we're already saying is true
will be true.
So I guess my question is,
in the context of a spring,
like, there's
obviously-- there exists
a physical threshold at which--
that's not infinitely slow,
and which you can get a
reasonable measurement
if you're doing an experiment.
PROFESSOR: So in
all of these things,
I would sort of resort to some
kind of a limiting procedure.
So you could, for example, pull
the spring at some velocity,
and figure out what
the amount of work is,
and gradually reduce
that velocity,
and hope that the formula--
the values-- that you get
are converging to something
as you go to low velocity.
I don't think there's
actually a threshold velocity,
kind of implied that if you
are slower than something, then
it would work.
I think it really only works
in the limit of zero velocity.
And so if you like,
that's kind of procedure
you would use to define
derivatives, right?
So you can't say what's the
meaning of velocity in physics.
So, but it is an idealization.
I said at the beginning
that the very-- actually, I
would say that
more fundamentally,
the thing that is
really an idealization
is this adiabatic walls.
Even the concept
of equilibrium--
what do we see around us
that we are absolutely
100% sure in equilibrium?
Nothing is.
The fate of the universe is that
all of our atoms and molecules
are going to separate out
and go to infinity, if it
expands forever.
Right?
OK, Second Law--
all right, so again,
we want to sort of
set our minds back
to where these laws
were developed,
which is in the 18th century.
And the thing that was of
importance at that time
was sort of Industrial
Revolution-- get things moving.
You need energy, and you
would get energy from coal,
and so you need to
convert heat to work.
And this conversion of heat
to work is important to you.
So typical thing that you
have for your coal engine
is you have something
that is a source of heat.
So there's, for example, a
fire that you're burning.
You have some kind
of a machine that
has components, such as a
piston, that is being heated.
And during this process,
you extract a certain amount
of heat from your fire.
And then typically,
you realize that you
will be releasing a
certain amount of energy
back to the atmosphere,
causing pollution.
So there is a coal sink.
But in the process,
you will be extracting
a certain amount of work.
And what you want
to do is to make
the best use of this set up.
So you're concerned
with efficiency,
which is defined to
be the amount of work
that you're going to extract
out of a certain amount of heat
that you expend in
your coal, or whatever.
And again, based on
conservation of energy,
we expect that this W to be
less than QH by an amount
that you are setting
to the exhaust.
And because of that, this
eta has to be less than
or equal to 1, in principal.
Now, another device that is
using the same rough principles
is the same thing
going in reverse,
which is a refrigerator.
So in order to
cool this room, you
use electricity or
some other means
of doing work on a machine whose
job it is to extract heat out
of the room.
So let's say this is our room.
We want to extract the heat.
But of course, that heat
has to go somewhere.
So this has to have
some kind of exhaust
putting this again to the
atmosphere or somewhere.
So how good is this
thing performing?
So there is a measure of the
performance-- figure of merit,
if you like, for
this-- which we will
label by omega, which is
how much heat you were
able to remove from the room
given some amount of work
or energy that was put in.
And again, because of
conservation, this W
is going to be QH minus QC.
Now, this particular
number, which
is a useful measure of how
well your refrigerator works,
has no particular constraint.
It can be less than 1.
It can be larger than 1.
So again, you want it to
be as large as possible,
and in principle, it
can be 200-- whatever.
So clearly, already
these are very much
idealizations of some
complicated process
that is going on.
And the thing that
is interesting
is that you can take
a look at how well you
are able to do these
processes, and then
make this equation
that we wrote up here
to be an exact
differential form.
So how you do that is an
interesting thing that I think
is worth repeating
and exploring.
And essentially, you do
that by formulating things
that are possible
or not possible
through the Second
Law, and then doing
some mathematical manipulations.
And we will use two
formulations of the Second Law
due to Kevin and Clausius.
So I will indicate them
either by K for Kelvin--
so Kelvin's statement
of the Second Law
is the following-- no process
is possible whose sole result
is complete conversion
of heat to work.
So what that is, is a statement
about how good an engine
you can make.
He says that you cannot make
an engine that takes a certain
amount of heat and completely
makes it to work without having
any waste QC.
So basically, it says that
there is no ideal engine,
and that your eta has
to be less than 1.
There is a second
variant of this,
which is due to Clausius-- says
that no process is possible
whose sole result is transfer
of heat from cold to hot.
So if you want to make
an ideal refrigerator,
what you want to do is
to extract more and more
QC for less and less
W. So the ideal version
would be where essentially,
the limit of zero
work, you would still
be able to transfer heat
from the room to the outside
and get an ideal refrigerator.
And Clausius says that
it's not possible.
So these are two statements
of the Second Law.
There are other versions and
statements of the Second Law,
but these are kind of most close
to this historical perspective.
And then the question is,
well, which one of them
do you want to use?
And since I will be
kind of switching
between using one
or the other, it
would be good if I can
show that they really
are the same statement,
and I'm really
not making use of two
different statements when
I use one or the
other alternative.
So what I really want to do is
to show that these are really,
logically, the same statement.
And essentially,
what that means is
that the two statements
are equivalent.
And two statements are
equivalent to each other
if one of them being
incorrect-- which I've indicated
by K with a bar on it-- implies
that the other one is correct,
and simultaneously,
the other way around.
And since this does not take
more than a few minutes,
and is a nice exercise, I
think it's worth showing this.
So let's say that
somebody came to you
and said that I have
constructed a machine that
violates Clausius.
We'll call that K bar.
So what does that machine do?
What that machine does
is it converts heat, Q,
completely to work, without
needing to exhaust anything.
So this W is this Q, and
there's no exhaust machine.
He says, OK I have this machine.
I say, OK, what I will do
is I will use that work
to run a refrigerator.
So I connect that
to a refrigerator.
And that work will be used to
take heat, QC, out of some room
and exhaust it to
the atmosphere.
And I will choose
the exhaust location
to be the same as
the source of heat
that I had for my
anti-Kelvin machine.
OK?
So then if you look at how
the sum of these two machines
is operating together, from
the perspective of looking
at the sum of the two
machines, the work
is just an internal operation.
You don't really care.
So as far as the net thing is
concerned, what you're seeing
is that there is no work
involved externally.
It's all internal.
But what is happening
is that you're
pulling QC out of the room,
and exhausting, presumably,
what you have here-- QH
minus Q to the other side.
This, again, by conservation of
energy must be the same as QC,
right?
So if you have a machine
that violates Kelvin,
you connect it to a
refrigerator, and what you have
is a machine that transfers
heat from a cold-air
to a hot-air body,
and violates Clausius.
So that's the first part
we have established.
And to establish
the second part,
let's say that we have a
machine that violates Clausius.
And this machine takes a
certain amount of heat, Q,
from the room, and deposits
it to the hotter outside.
What we will do
immediately is to take
some of this heat that has
been generated by this machine
and use it in a regular engine
to create some amount of work.
And then this has to take
an amount of heat QH,
deposit an amount of heat, QC,
which we will select to be,
essentially, the temperature
or the room from which
the anti Clausius
machine is operating.
And then we will run this
engine several times,
or fractions of times, et
cetera, and the other machine
several times, ensuring that
QC is the same as Q. That
is, the engine puts
out as much dumped heat
as this anti-Clausius machine
is extracting from the room.
Then if you look at the
combined system, what
we see is that the combined
system is doing the following--
this was equivalent to this.
This is equivalent
to a combined system
that does a certain
amount of work.
So there is a W
that is coming out.
There is no heat
exchange with the room,
because we ensured that these
two heats are completely
balanced.
So you can sort of think
of them as something
that is internal to
this bigger machine.
And so what is happening
is that there's
a certain amount of heat, QH
minus Q that is taken here
that has to be equal to W,
by conservation of energy.
And we have converted
heat entirely
to work, violating
Kelvin's statement.
So basically, we
have proved this.
Any questions?
OK, one more step-- there
is actually a couple
more steps left before we get to
construct our entropy function.
And the next step is
the Carnot Engine.
So this is yet another
one of these idealizations
that-- again, theoretical
construct, which you
can try to approach as in
some limiting procedure.
A Carnot engine is any engine
with the following properties--
that is, one, reversible,
two, operates in a cycle,
and three, all inputs--
all heat inputs--
outputs at two temperatures.
OK, so let's go
through the conditions.
Reversible implies
that at any stage,
if I change the directions
of inputs and outputs,
it will just go backward.
So can go forward, backward,
by reversing inputs, outputs.
And so again, think of
the case of our spring
that we were pushing
back and forth.
In order for it to have this
property of reversibility,
I should not only do it pulling
down and up sufficiently slowly
so that at each stage, I
can define its tension,
but also as far
as its connection
to the outside world, I have
to do it frictionlessly,
so that if I were to reverse
the direction of the force
that I have, it will either go
forward or backward, reversing
the path that it has.
If there is any friction
that is involved,
then I cannot do that.
So essentially,
this reversibility
is some kind of a generalization
of the frictionless condition
that we would use in mechanics.
The cycle part is easy.
Essentially, it says
that the start and end
points are the same.
And it kind of harks
back to this statement
that is part of either
one of these formulations
of the Second Law--
that is the net result
or sole result is something.
So we want the
engine to essentially
be back to where it
was, so that when
we are looking at changes
that are involved,
we say, OK, the engine is
not part of the equation.
It is where it was
at the beginning
and at the end of the cycle.
Now there's something
that I didn't emphasize,
but I was-- and actually,
I was not really using,
but you may have
thought I was using--
is that in all of these
pictures that I drew,
I said there is a hot place
and there's a cold place.
Now, I didn't specify
exactly what these are,
and whether this corresponds
to a particular temperature.
Now, for the case of the Carnot
engine, I have to be precise.
I have to say that this is
always at one temperature.
This is always at the
other temperature.
So these Carnot engines
are defined implicitly
with two temperature
labels corresponding
to the hot part
and the cold part.
In principle, everything
else that I talked about
could have had a
range of temperatures.
But the Carnot engine says,
OK, just two temperatures.
OK, so for the Carnot
engine, if I can now
draw a diagram that would
be kind of straight line
version of what I had before.
And the Carnot engine will be
extracting a certain amount
of heat, QH, from
here, QC from here,
doing a certain amount of work.
And since it is reversible, I
could actually run it backward.
I could have W. I
could have QH, QC,
and it would work
as a refrigerator.
Now, it is good to have
at least one example--
that such a theoretical
construct as a Carnot engine
can be made based on
things that we have so far.
And we can be
explicit, and show that
for the case of the ideal gas.
So we said that a gas I
can represent in equivalent
by a point in the
pressure-volume diagram.
So let's say that
what is the working
substance of this
Carnot engine is a gas.
And part of this
whole story is that it
should be working between two
isotherms-- the TH and TC.
But we've already
established that we
can have isotherms for the
ideal gas that correspond
to these curves that
correspond to PV as constant.
So I could really choose
one of the isotherms
that we discussed before
corresponds to TH.
One corresponds to TC.
And I can imagine taking a gas
whose initial state is point A,
and expanding it while
maintaining it at this isotherm
TH, and ending up
at some point B.
So as I'm expanding this,
let's say we have put this gas.
I have this piston
that contains this gas.
My TH and TC
correspond to two baths
that correspond to, if you
like, lakes-- a temperature
TH, lakes at temperature TC.
I took my piston, put
it into the hot bath,
make it expand up to some point.
And in the process,
there is certainly
a certain amount of heat that
will go into the system, QH.
So I have taken QH
out of the hot source.
Now, next thing
that I want to do
is to take this, and put
it into the colder lake.
But what the process is,
is I have to do it in a way
that there is no heat exchange.
So I have to find the path
that goes from the hot bath
to the cold path-- to
point C, some point C--
without any heat involved.
We'll have to ask
how that's possible,
and what's the
structure of that path.
Once I'm in the
colder bath, then I
can expand my gas
up to some point D.
And clearly, I have to choose
this point D sufficiently
precisely so that
then, when I take
my gas from the cool to
the original hot position,
I end up at precisely the
location that I started,
so that I have
completed a cycle.
So it's necessary
that I should be
able to construct these
two paths, BC and DA, that
correspond to no heat exchange.
And somehow I'm sure that
I can complete this cycle.
So the paths BC
and DA are called
adiabats, or adiabatic
paths, in the sense
that this is what
you would get if you
put your system in a container
with these adiabatic walls that
allows no exchange of heat.
Now clearly, I also want to
do this sufficiently slowly
so that infinitesimally,
I can draw
this path as a series of points.
And so I don't want to do what
was in the Joule expansion
experiment, and suddenly
expand the whole thing.
I have to do it
sufficiently slowly
so that the conditions of this
Carnot engine are satisfied.
So along these paths,
what do I know?
By definition dQ is 0.
And dQ is dE minus
dW along those paths.
And since I'm performing these
paths sufficiently slowly,
I can write the W
as PdV minus PdV.
Now, what you will show
in the problem set is
that I don't need to make any
assumption about the functional
form of energy on P and V. Just
knowing that I'm describing
a system that is characterized
by two coordinates, P and V,
is sufficient for you to
construct these curves.
Turns out that if you
have more than two
coordinates-- three or four
coordinates-- at this time
you don't know that you
will be able to do so.
But we're sticking with this.
For simplicity, I'm going
to choose this-- the form
that I have for the ideal gas,
which I know that it's really
a function only
of the product PV.
This is what we had used before.
And again, so as to
simplify the algebra,
I will use the form that is
applicable to a monoatomic gas.
And this-- I really have
no reason to do this,
except that I want to be
able to get through this
in two minutes with the algebra.
So I will write the
energy to be 3/2 PV.
So then for that particular
choice, what I have here
is d of 3/2 PV plus PdV.
And that's 3/2 PdV plus
V, 3/2 VdP plus PdV,
which is 5/2 PdV
plus 3/2 VdP is 0.
And you can
rearrange that easily
to dP over P plus
5/3 dV over V is 0.
And this is simply the
derivative of log of PV
to the power of 5/3.
And since this
derivative is 0, you
know that along the curves that
correspond to no heat exchange,
you have something like
PV to the power of gamma--
in this case, gamma being
5/3-- that is some constant.
So after you have done your
expansion, all you need is to,
in this diagram, go
continuously along the path
that corresponds to this
formula that we have indicated.
And this formula
describes a path
that is distinct
from the isotherm.
So you start from somewhere.
You start along some path.
You are guaranteed to hit the
other isotherm at some point.
You start from the
starting point.
You go backward.
You're guaranteed to hit
the isotherm at some point.
And then you join
those two points,
and you've completed your cycle.
And so you know that, at least
for the case of the ideal gas,
or actually for any
two-coordinate system,
you can construct
a cardinal cycle.
That is, put your material,
go through a cycle that
is reversible with all heat
exchanges at two temperatures
only.
OK, now why is this
idealization even useful?
Well, we said that
this Carnot engine
is stamped by really two
temperatures-- TH and TC.
And the following
theorem is important,
which says that of all
engines operating only
between TH and TC, the Carnot
engine is most efficient.
So we are going to move
away from this idealization
that we've made, but so
far, only in one small step.
That is, we are still going
to assume that all heat
exchanges are done
between TH and TC.
OK, and so let's
say that we have
some kind of an engine which
does not have to be reversible.
So because it does not
have to be reversible,
it's not a Carnot engine, but
otherwise, operates completely
between these two points.
So it takes, let's say,
heat QH prime, QC prime,
and does a certain
amount of work W.
And so somebody
comes and says, I've
constructed this engine
that is actually very good.
It's better than
your Carnot engine.
I say, no, that's not possible.
And the way that I
will prove it to you
is as follows-- I will take
the output of your engine,
connect it to a Carnot engine,
and since the Carnot engine
can be run backward, it
will act as a refrigerator
and extract heat and
deposit heat precisely
at the two temperatures that
your engine is operating.
So if somebody looks at the
combination of these two,
what do they see?
The thing that they
see for the combination
is that there is
some entity that
is operating between TH and TC.
And there is some
internal amount of work
that is going on, and you
don't care about that.
But there is a certain amount
of heat, QH prime minus QH that
becomes QC prime minus QC.
Now here we invoke Clausius.
Clausius says that if you
see heat going between two
temperatures, it could have only
gone from the direction hotter
to colder, which means
that this amount of heat
has to be positive.
QH prime should be
greater than QH.
So this is why Clausius-- we
know that this has to be case.
So then what I can do, is I can
divide both expressions by W.
And then invert this thing.
And if I invert it, the
inequality gets inverted.
So I get that W over QH
prime is less than W over QH.
And the left-hand
side is the efficiency
of my non-Carnot engine.
And the right-hand side is the
efficiency of my Carnot engine.
Carnot And what I've shown
is that the efficiency
of the non-Carnot engine
has to be less than
or equal to the efficiency
of the Carnot engine.
OK, now, the next step
is the following--
that all Carnot engines
operating between TH and TC
have the same efficiency.
And the statement is, suppose
I have two different Carnot
engines-- Carnot engine
one and Carnot engine two.
I can use one to run
the other one backward,
and I would get that the
efficiency of Carnot engine one
is less than or equal to Carnot
engine two, or the other way
around-- that two is less
than or equal to one.
And hence, the
only possibility is
that they are the same, which
is actually interesting,
because I told you that
Carnot engines are stamped
by two temperatures, TH and TC.
And what it says
is that they all
have an efficiency that
is a function, therefore,
of these two temperatures only.
It cannot depend on whether I
constructed my Carnot engine
out of an ideal gas.
I constructed it
out of a rubber band
that I was pulling or pushing,
or any other substance
in the world that
you can think about,
as long as that substance I can
construct some kind of a Carnot
cycle, irrespective of what the
coordinate systems are, what
the isotherms look
like, et cetera.
Just working between two
temperatures and two isotherms
tells me that this
reversible cycle
will have this efficiency
relating the amount of work
and the amount of heat
that these exchange as you
go around.
OK?
Now, that's important
because previously we
wanted to define
our temperature.
And we had to rely on
some property of the gas.
We said OK, empirically we
observe that for the gas,
you have this relationship
that when it is dilute,
PV is proportional to T and we
use that property of the gas
to construct our ideal
gas temperature scale.
Well, that's OK, but it
relies on some observations
additionally to everything
else that we had.
Whereas now we have the
means to define temperatures
irrespective of any material.
This is much more of
a universal quantity.
It' doesn't depend
on any substance,
any particular structure.
So it's a much
better way to rely
for constructing a
temperature scale.
So in some sense, at
least theoretically,
we are going to abandon
our previous temperature
scale based on properties
of the ideal gas,
and reconstruct the temperature
scale based on this.
Any questions?
OK.
So this is what will be called
the thermodynamic temperature
scale.
And what it amounts
to is that somehow I
use the efficiency
between two temperatures
or vice versa-- use that
there are two temperatures.
Let's say one of them is
a reference temperature.
I derive the temperature
of the other one
by the maximum efficiency
of all engines that
can operate between
the reference
temperature and the temperature
that I wish to measure.
It's T.
But that means I--
before doing that, I
need to know at least something,
or some kind of a postulate
about the structure of this
function of two variables.
And I cannot write any
arbitrary function.
It has to satisfy certain
properties and symmetries.
And I can see what
those properties are
by putting a couple of
these engines in series.
So let's imagine that we
have a structure where
I have the highest
temperature T1,
and intermediate temperature T2,
and the lowest temperature T3.
And I put one Carnot engine
to operate between these two
temperatures, and one to operate
between these temperatures.
And the first one is
going to take heat
that I will called Q1.
And release a heat that I will
call Q2, in the process doing
a certain amount of work that
I will call W between 1 and 2.
Now what I will do is I will use
the entirety of that heat, Q2,
to run the second Carnot
engine to temperature T3,
reducing here the
amount of heat, Q3,
and doing a certain
amount of work-- W23.
Clearly what I want
to do is to say
that when I look at the
combination of these things,
what happens at temperature
2 is an intermediate.
And the whole thing is
equivalent to a Carnot engine
operating between T1 and T3.
Again, the whole
thing is reversible,
operates between
two temperatures,
and since each
one of them can be
made to go back to where
they started, is a cycle.
So the whole thing is really
equivalent to another Carnot
engine that takes
Q1, deposits Q3, does
a certain amount
of work, W13, which
is the sum of W12 plus W23.
So clearly, these two
different perspectives
on the same operation
will constrain
some-- give some
constraint between the form
of the functions that
will be describing
the efficiencies
of Carnot engines.
So let's follow
that mathematically.
OK, so the first
one-- what do we have?
By conservation
of energy, I have
that Q2 is-- so this
is-- let me be precise.
This is Carnot engine 1-- tells
me that Q2 is Q1 minus W12.
All right, so how
much heat I have here
is the difference between
this and the amount of work
that I did--
conservation of energy.
W12 is the efficiency times Q.
That was how it was defined.
So it is 1 minus the efficiency
operating between T1 and T2
times Q1.
What do we know about
Carnot engine number 2?
Carnot engine
number 2 says that I
can look at Q3 as being
the difference between Q2
minus the work that
is done over here.
The work is related to the
heat through multiplying
by the efficiency that is
operating between T2 and T3.
And if I substitute for Q2
from the first equation, what
do I get?
I will get Q2 being Q1,
1 minus efficiency T1,
T2, multiplying by the
second bracket that
is 1 minus efficiency T2 T3.
But I can also look at the
composite Carnot engine-- that
is the sum total
of them represented
by the diagram on the right.
And what that states-- just
writing the whole thing
same way-- is that this
Q3 is the same as Q1
minus this amount of W13,
which is the same thing as Q1,
1 minus the efficiency
between T1 and T3.
So suddenly you see that
I have two equations that
relate Q3 and Q1-- essentially
two formulations of this ratio.
And what that says is that the
efficiency functions calculated
between pairs of
temperatures, when
we look at triplet of them,
have to be related by 1 minus
efficiency between T1 and T3 is
1 minus efficiency between T1
and T2, 1 minus efficiency
between T2 and T3.
So when we are constructing
our temperature scale
based on properties of
this efficiency function,
we better choose and
efficiency function
that satisfies this equality.
And very roughly again, where
did this type of equality
come from?
It originated in the fact that
this 1 minus eta was the ratio
of two Q's.
This was the ratio
of Q2 over Q1,
and then the other
one was Q1 over Q3,
and you would
multiply them, and you
would get Q2 over Q3, et cetera.
And that gives you
a hint as to how
you should construct
this function
to satisfy the
property that you want.
If I write the function as the
ratio of some function of T2
divided by some
function of T1, it
would cancel in
precisely the same way
that when you were
multiplying Q2's and Q1's,
the cancellations occur.
OK?
So what I need to
do is to postulate
that this is of this form.
And then actually, I'm
free to choose any function
or form for F that I want.
So here we need to
make a convention.
And the convention
that we make--
so this is-- this
was not required--
is that this is really the
functional form is linear.
So this defines for you the
thermodynamic temperature
scale.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: Yes, the
part, the step right
before the convention, where
you wrote F of T1 over T1,
is this also an assumption,
or is it a necessity?
PROFESSOR: I'm,
let's say, 99.9% sure
that it's a
mathematical necessity.
I can't-- at this stage, think
of precisely how to make that--
actually, yes, I
can make that rigor.
So essentially think of writing
this in the following way-- 1
minus eta of T1 and T2 equals
to 1 minus eta of T1 and T3,
1 minus eta of T2 and T3.
OK?
The left-hand side
depends on T1 and T2.
The right-hand side is the
ratio of two functional forms
involving T1 and T2 precisely
as you have over here,
as long as you regard
T3 to be some arbitrary
parameter or constant.
OK?
So that's the proof.
All right, unfortunately,
it's like doing magic.
Once you reveal the trick, it
becomes not so interesting.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: Does that
mean more precisely
if we assumed that
T2 and T1 using F
are empirical
temperatures, and we define
the different temperature to
be F [INAUDIBLE] 2, something
like that?
PROFESSOR: OK, what I wanted to
say next maybe answers to that.
So why don't I give that
answer first, and then
come back to you?
Is that so far, we have
defined two temperatures.
There is the thermodynamic
temperature scale
based on these efficiencies and
there is one other statement,
which is that this only
defines the ratios.
So I need to also pick
a reference temperature.
And for reference temperature,
I pick the temperature
of the coexistence
of ice, steam, water,
to be 273.16 degrees
K, which is what
I have for the ideal gas scale.
Because if I don't
do that, I only
know things up to some
proportionality constant.
If I say that I pick that
reference temperature, then
in principle what I could do
is, if somebody gives me a bath,
I can run a Carnot
engine between that bath
of unknown temperature
and this reference point,
calculate the efficiency,
1 minus the efficiency,
use this ratio--
273.16-- and I have
the temperature
of my new object.
So we've completed that
thermodynamic temperature
scale.
If I understood correctly
the question that was posed,
is, well, what about the
empirical temperature?
And I was going to answer
something different, which
is not really what
you were asking.
So maybe you can repeat
your question one more time.
AUDIENCE: If the, all
of our computations
where we assume that instead
of T's, there are some thetas.
PROFESSOR: Right.
AUDIENCE: And which means
that we use the [INAUDIBLE]
at last we define the
thermodynamic temperature,
it seems to have more precise.
PROFESSOR: That's fine.
So you're saying that what I
did with the Zeroth Law was
to state that for somebody that
exists in thermal equilibrium
with a bath, I can
characterize it with the theta.
And I can go through
the whole argument
that I had over here
by constructing,
let's say, Carnot
engines that operate
between empirical temperatures
defined as theta H and theta C.
And nowhere in the
process have I given you
a number for what theta H and
theta C is up to this point.
And at this point, I
defined efficiency,
which I have established
is only a function
of the empirical temperature
operating between two
isotherms, as some way
through this process
and this definition, giving
an actual numerical value.
So that's fine.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: So should you also
define temperature [INAUDIBLE]
with ideal gas and
infinite expansion?
PROFESSOR: Yes.
AUDIENCE: And doesn't it define
what convention for effective
we need to pick here?
So for all the definitions to
be consistent with each other?
PROFESSOR: OK, so now that
becomes a different question.
So I think the
first question was,
let's not define any temperature
scale up to this point.
And this is the first time that
we define a temperature scale.
Now, your question
is the one that I
wanted to originally
answer, so thank you
for the question, which
is that I actually
did define for you a temperature
scale through some property
of the ideal gas.
And indeed, that
property of the ideal gas
I implicitly used here in
the shape of the isotherms
that I had and
constructing this energy
functional in this fashion.
Now you say well,
OK, you defined
temperature two different ways.
Are they consistent
with each other?
And you will have
a problem set that
will ask the following
question-- let's
run an ideal gas Carnot cycle
between ideal gas temperatures
theta H and theta C. OK?
Now you can-- and I
have drawn for you
the form of this Carnot cycle.
Using PdV, you can calculate
what amount of work
goes into this at
different stages.
And the net work would be
the area of this cycle.
So W would give you
the area of the cycle.
You can calculate what QH is.
And you can calculate
the efficiency
of this as a function
theta H and theta C.
And what you will find, if
you do things correctly,
is that using all of these
definitions for the shapes
of these isotherms,
you can calculate
what the efficiency is.
And the answer for
your efficiency
will come out to be
theta H minus theta
C divided by theta H, which is
precisely what you would have
expected based on
the Carnot cycle.
So then you can
establish that the ratio
of theta H to theta C
defined through the ideal gas
temperature scale is the same
as the ratio of the temperatures
if you had defined
through the thermodynamic.
So the two scales, once
you set the same point
for both of them,
become identical.
Other questions?
OK, so we went
through all of this
in order to ultimately
get back to the story
that I was constructing at the
beginning of the lecture, which
was that I'd like to have the
form ultimately for my energy.
I want to construct the energy.
And if I was looking only
at mechanical systems,
and there was no
temperature in the world,
I would construct it
as sum over i Ji dxi.
But I know that
that's not enough,
because there are processes
by which I can change
the state by not doing any
mechanical work-- go from one
point in the diagram to
another point in the diagram.
So there must be something else.
Now we said that it kind
of makes a lot of sense
that something else should be
something like a temperature.
And before that,
really, the only thing
that we had that was
a form of temperature
was the ideal gas temperature,
or the empirical temperature
that we had defined
through the Zeroth Law.
And neither of them had any
nice connection to heat.
Through this Carnot
engines, et cetera you
have established some kind of
a connection between heats,
temperatures, et cetera.
And that's why this
thermodynamic temperature
scale is useful.
It is independent
of any material.
And it's really the T
that I should put here.
And so the next question
is, what should I put here?
And that will also come
through the Second Law.
I will develop that mostly
the next time around,
but I'll give you in the next
two or three minutes a preview.
So the statement that we
had was that the efficiency
of any engine is less than
the Carnot engine, right?
So let's imagine that we
have some kind of a exchange
process going between TH and TC.
And there is some
engine-- I don't
know what that engine is--
that takes heat QH here, QC
here, and does a
certain amount of work.
Now I know that W
over QH is less than
or equal to 1 minus TH over TC.
And W is really the same
thing as QH minus QC.
So actually, I could
also have written this
as 1 minus QC over QH is
less than 1 minus TC over TC.
I can eliminate the 1,
and rearrange things, yes?
AUDIENCE: It's TC over TH.
PROFESSOR: 1 minus TC over
TH, thank you very much.
Yes, and if you ever
forget-- not that I forgot--
I miswrote-- but something to
remember is that ultimately,
I was kind of hinting this--
if you ever forget Q's are
proportional to T's.
So what I have is that ideally,
QH will be proportional to TH.
QC will be proportional to TC.
So the difference
between them would
be proportional to
the differences.
Also, that means that if I were
to rearrange this slightly,
what I would get is that QH
over TH plus minus QC over TC
has to be negative.
So this is just a rearrangement
of the whole thing.
But this rearrangement--
I wrote this as minus
QC so as to look at things from
the perspective of the engine.
So the engine is something
that goes through a cycle.
As part of that cycle,
it does some work.
But what this
expression has to do
is the heat that
goes into the system.
So I can regard minus
QC as the heat that
goes into the engine coming from
a reservoir of temperature TC,
QH going through
the engine, coming
from a reservoir
of temperature TH.
And you have a
relation such as this
because the efficiency
of any type of engine
has to be less than this
efficiency of the Carnot engine
that is stamped by the
corresponding temperatures.
OK, now this is kind of limited.
And in order to be able to
construct a general formula,
we need to be able
to make statements
that's are relevant to
arbitrary complex cycles
and complex behaviors.
So what we will
start next time is
to prove something
that ultimately
will allow us to
quantify entropy.
It's called Clausius'
Theorem, which
states the following-- imagine
some kind of a generalization
of your engine that takes place
in some multidimensional space.
So rather than really
thinking about an engine,
I want to think
about some substance.
This was an ideal gas run
through some nice cycle.
But I want to think
about some substance that
is described by multiple
coordinate system.
I take the system
from some point A,
and the only requirement
that I place on it
is that ultimately,
I do something,
and I come back to
A. So it is a cycle.
What I don't even
require is that this
is a quasistatic process, so
that the intermediate stages
are well-defined in
this coordinate space--
OK, so for any arbitrary
cyclic transformation.
OK, now this
transformation-- we'll do
is that at various stages--
just like that simple example--
we'll do work on
the environment,
take work from the environment.
But most importantly
from our perspective,
there will be heat
input into the system
at various stages of the cycle.
And I'm going to look at it
from the perspective of what
goes into the system,
just like in this engine.
So sometimes maybe this
dQ is negative-- means
that the system is
really releasing heat,
just like this engine
was releasing the heat.
Now, Clausius' Theorem
says that if you integrate
all around the cycle,
these elements of heat
that you input to the system
throughout various stages
of the cyclic transformation,
and divide them by some T.
And this is kind of something
that needs definition.
And S is supposed to
parametrize the cycle.
Let's say S goes from 0 to 1
as you go across the cycle.
Generalizing that is negative.
Next time, we will see if this
system is non-equilibrium,
what exactly I mean
by this T of S.
And we will see, somehow,
that once I define this,
by doing part of
this, I can actually
define an entropy function
integral from A to B dQ over S,
and complete the definition of
what needs to be put for the Q
in order to give you an
expression for T. OK.